[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu einer spezialausgabe von 485
köpfe fünf meinungen seit neun tagen
wird die putins furchtbar krieg die
kämpfe
ukrainische atomkraftwerk sabres jahr
hätten nach ansicht der usa leicht zu
einem desaster führen können die new
yorker metropolitan opera und andere
opernhäuser legen die zusammenarbeit mit
opernstar der sopranistin netrebko auf
eis und die g7-staaten kündigen weitere
noch strengere sanktionen an was
passiert wenn putin verliert und was
wenn er siegt wie weit wir punkten noch
gehen und kommt jetzt der dritte
weltkrieg auf uns zu darüber möchte ich
heute abend meinen gästen debattieren
mit bild chefredakteur und tv chef claus
strunz bei dem früheren generalsekretär
der cdu und bundestagsabgeordneten jörg
der uns aus seinem wahlkreis
zugeschaltet ist mit dem
stellvertretenden chefredakteur und für
den r8 host ports heime der uns wie
jeden abend aus kiew zugeschaltet ist
paul ist eine der wenigen journalisten
die überhaupt noch vor ort sind was
seine information so wertvoll macht last
but not least der militärexperte gustav
presse der kürzlich sagte für putin soll
russland ein imperium sein und lassen
sie uns direkt starten mit paul
ronzheimer paul die frage die uns
natürlich alle bewegt wie ist der neunte
kriegstag was hast du heute erlebt
ja das geräusch was mittlerweile auch
viele viertel nach acht zuschauer kennen
nämlich die sirene die ist heute sehr
sehr häufig wieder losgegangen zuletzt
ungefähr vor 10 minuten und wir haben
hier in der nähe des zentrums ebenfalls
mehrere explosionen gehört jetzt muss
man abwarten aber um ein gefühl zu
vermitteln kann ich sagen jeder in kiew
fragt sich an so einem vorhaben bevor
man schlafen geht wird ist heute nacht
die gefährlichste nach wird es heute den
großen angriff geben und allein das ist
ein wahnsinniger psychoterror die auf
den menschen lastet die noch hier sind
ich war heute am bahnhof habe dort
rührende szenen erlebt frauen die sich
verabschiedet haben von ihren männern
die hier bleiben und kämpfen junge
frauen die ihre hunde und haustiere mit
neben nur aus in den westen nach lemberg
und dann habe ich petro poroschenko
getroffen den ehemaligen präsidenten der
ukraine nachdem ich gestern den
präsidenten selensky getroffen hat und
obwohl beide erbitterte konkurrenten
sind haben sie etwas gemeinsam sie
glauben dass der westen putin immer noch
unterschätzt dass der westen immer noch
nicht verstanden hat wie gefährlich es
wird wenn putin in der ukraine
erfolgreich ist peter schwenkow sagt
putin ist ein killer und terrorist er
fordert die flugverbotszone genauso wie
sie lenski und genauso wie lance gesagt
der wenn putin hier nicht aufgehalten
wird dann geht er weiter dann kommen die
baltischen staaten dran oder wie sie
lenski gestern sagte dann geht er bis
ost berlin der ist ja die große angst
viele menschen hier in deutschland haben
mich inklusive die man jeden tag spürt
wo geht er hin wie weit wird putin noch
gehen und hier meine frage an dich mit
der beton einschätzung was ist denn
wahrscheinlicher wird er nach georgien
gehen oder doch wenn er dann weitergehen
sollte ein nato gebiet angreifen
er ist momentan natürlich viel zu
beschäftigt mit der ukraine als dass er
einen weiteren krieg anfangen würde
militärisch läuft es nicht so wie er es
vielleicht gehofft hat aber auch da
gehen die analysen auseinander manche
sagen vielleicht nutzt er diese taktik
einfach um diesen ja dieser angst diese
psycho angst auf das land zu legen und
danach aber wenn die ukraine so
vernichtet sein sollte wie er sagt
nämlich sagt die ukraine existiert gar
nicht sie gehört zu russland dann traue
ich ihm alles zu natürlich ist ein nato
staat und auch die nato wird sich jetzt
weiter wappnen eine größere hürde aber
wladimir putin und das sagen alle
beobachter ist nicht mehr
zurechnungsfähig und das macht ihn so
gefährlich
werde es der tätigen farbe steht ja wie
sie paul beschreibt ganz real und die
psychologie die dahinter steckt ist ja
das eigentlich beklemmende also wenn ich
alles richtig sehe ist im moment eine
situation angerichtet das land mir putin
machen kann was er will wenn er
deutschland bombardieren will
bombardiert der deutschland dann können
wir schauen wie wir uns da verteidigen
und was unsere antwort ist wenn er in
anderen ländern einmarschieren will die
es sich noch einverleiben will in seine
großmacht fantasien dann tut er das
diesen proof of concept diese
bestätigung dass der westen dann erst
mal diskutiert und natürlich in der
ständigen sorge die reaktion des westens
löst dann den dritten weltkrieg oder
zumindest eine große eskalation aus dass
genau dass das szenario ist das schmerzt
einem jahr schon wenn man es ausspricht
weil man irgendwie so machtlos wirkt
gegen jemand der sich nimmt was er will
und er ist hinterlegt mit der drohung
wenn ihr das nicht zu lasten noch viel
schlimmeres an das ist die groß ist der
große sachverhalt mit dem ist sie jetzt
auseinander zu setzen und das ist nicht
trivial und ich glaube auch dass alle
führer des westens sozusagen gänsehaut
haben wenn sie darüber nachdenken weil
putin ja auch geschafft hat das quasi
die eskalation im westen zu kommt also
die situation ist psychologischer jetzt
so angerichtet dass wenn der westen
reagiert gibt es eben die eskalation ich
will aber ein kleines hoffnungszeichen
dahinter machen oder auch nicht denn
wladimir putin sieht ja jetzt auch dass
seine armee vielleicht nicht ganz so
stark ist wie er selber und auch der
westen gedacht hat dass der soldaten hat
die ihre panzer im stich lassen nur
zurück nach russland laufen das im
schlamm stecken bleibt dass er viel
stärker ist als die ukraine das hat er
auch gelernt aber dass er möglicherweise
nicht stark genug ist die
auseinandersetzung die militärische
auseinandersetzung mit dem westlichen
bündnis aufzunehmen das kommt ihm auch
in den sinn und jetzt kommt aber der
entscheidende punkt es ist bei einem wie
ihm wahrscheinlich sogar egal dass er
begreift dass das eine große gefahr ist
er provoziert sie zu seinem vorteil und
im moment wenn man fazit zieht liegt
davon in der auseinandersetzung er ist
in der ukraine
er hat den psychologischen punkt auf
seiner seite wie eben beschrieben und
der westen weiß nicht so recht was er
machen soll als in seiner agenda
voranzuschreiten die aber endlich herr
zehn jahre liegt putin vorerst mal
vielen dank dass er sich die zeit nehmen
dass sie sich heute zugeschaltet haben
aus ihrem wahlkreis vielen herzlichen
dank legt putin vorne also hat herr
strunz recht dass putin aktuell vorne
liegt
ja militärisch hat er vieles in der hand
in der ukraine weil er über starke
streitkräfte verfügt aber ich sehe nicht
dass putin vorne liegt denn er hat sich
selbst in eine ziemlich ausweglose
situation politisch gebracht er hatte
russland international isoliert die
sanktionen greifen jetzt es gibt
diskussionen ob sie noch härter sein
könnten und müssten ich glaube auch dass
wir darüber sprechen müssen was man noch
mehr tun kann aber diese sanktionen die
es jetzt schon gibt treffen putin hart
und er muss jetzt überlegen wie kommt er
aus dieser situation heraus und in einem
punkt würde ich ansturms widersprechen
das ist die frage wie reagiert der
westen wäre ja geht die jugend vor allem
die nato wenn er weiter gehen würde
gegenüber einem nato staat da sind die
aussagen glasklar dass auch dass die
nato generalsekretärs aber auch aller
regierungen östlich von uns jeder
quadratzentimeter von nato territorium
wird verteidigt und wird einen
sofortigen rückschlag der gesamten nato
nach sich ziehen das weiß putin es ist
für ihn ein gefährliches spiel deswegen
muss man unterscheiden zwischen der
situation in der ukraine und was würde
passieren wenn es zu einem vorfall käme
auf nato gebiet aber der punkt ist ja er
entscheidet dass das muss ja jeden der
gewohnt ist entscheidungen zu treffen
und das kennen sie ja aus ihrer liebe
auch das ist doch das was ein so
ohnmächtig wahrscheinlich ist er
bestimmt die agenda er tut etwas und wir
reagieren vielleicht angemessen
vielleicht nicht angemessen aber wie
reagieren aber er hat sozusagen die hand
am abzug und das ist das was den
menschen glaube ich angst macht weil es
sich bei ihm ihr offenbar um jemanden
handelt der zum allerschlimmsten
imstande ist er ist aber das ist eine
typische situation er ist nämlich der
aggressor er ist täter er ist nicht
opfer und es ist sind auch nicht zwei
parteien wissen sie wenn es einen
konflikt gebe wo beide seiten wo man
diskutieren könnte wie löst man ihn auch
weil beide berechtigte anliegen haben
das ist hier nicht der fall deswegen ist
diese situation so wie sie sie
beschreiben aber das ist typisch für
einen überall für einen angriffskrieg
dass der angreifer wird er die karten in
der hand hat und es ist etwas angetreten
und damit hat eingetreten damit hat
putin eben etwas getan was ihn zu dieser
situation jetzt bringt womit wir aber
auch nicht gerechnet haben ist dieser
überfall auf die gesamte ukraine
ich will aber dazu ein strengen wenn wir
sagen wir haben damit nicht gerechnet
wir haben in deutschland vielleicht
nicht damit gerechnet aber wenn ich mit
kolleginnen kollegen östlich von uns
spreche dann sagen sie mir es ist genau
das passiert was wir euch immer gesagt
haben und ihr habt es runter gespielt ja
business gemacht hab gesagt wenn die
wirtschaftsbeziehung stehen dann kann
das nicht hier und jetzt sind wir in der
realität angekommen so sagen es viele
leute in warschau und den anderen
hauptstädten aber eher zäh märkte dann
meinen wir sie damit also ihre partei
hat ja die regierung gestellt in den
letzten jahren das nehmen sie dann so
lässig zur kenntnis und sagen ja die
haben recht da wir haben jetzt unsere
fehler aufgedeckt oder wie gehen sie
damit um dass ja frontale kritik an der
politik ihrer kanzlerin ihre regierung
ihre verteidigungsminister ihrer ich
will es nicht sagen ihn an ihnen selbst
aber
das beschreiben sie jetzt irgendwie so
als sei es so ein historisches faktum
aber sie sind ja voll mit gewinnen
also ich persönlich habe die sachen auch
wenn nicht so wie das gesagt wurde in er
im beitragen und auch in polen und in
anderen staaten so hart habe es nicht
gesehen aber natürlich ja clijsters
kritik an uns natürlich ist es kritik an
uns all die dass wir beispielsweise
nicht unsere verpflichtungen in der nato
nach gekommen sind das war fahrlässig
aber ich will an dieser stelle mal sagen
derjenige der das verhindert hat als
finanzminister ist heute bundeskanzler
gut dass er die kehrtwende gemacht hat
aber wenn sie jetzt fragen wer hat das
verhindert es war nicht die union es
waren die sozialdemokraten die jetzt die
kehrtwende zu recht einläuten wir haben
es im wald roden waren gefordert schauen
sie sich mal die aussagen von saskia
esken an in der sie ja klipp und klar
gesagt hat die erklärung von annegret
kramp karrenbauer mehr für verteidigung
auszugeben das sei schockierend und das
würde es mit der spd nicht geben er
ziemlich erklärten gestern hier in der
region aktive die cdu hat ein putin
probleme nicht nur deswegen auch direkt
mal zu baumanns aber nachher
weiterleiten ist das so wie hat sie mir
das hier erklärt paul das ist nur die
spd ist also wenn eine partei ein putin
probleme hat dann ist sich die spd mit
denjenigen die in aufsichtsräten und
vorständen russischer staatskonzerne
sitzen die das geld dafür zur verfügung
stehen die cdu hatte diese positionen
aber ich bereue es nochmal ein jetzt
müssen wir die dinge mal drin die gefahr
eines krieges eines angriffskrieges
eines überfalls ruhig russland haben
viele auch ich so in dieser form nicht
kommen sehen
paul wir geben zudem ist gerade schon
was sagen wollen das habe ich zu spät
gehört war es was mir sozusagen aus der
ukrainischen perspektive immer mehr
auffällt in den letzten tagen ist dass
ich das gefühl gehabt dass sowohl
beobachter als auch experten die ukraine
eigentlich aufgegeben haben wissen sie
gerade hinter mir hat es wieder geknallt
die explosion vor 15 minuten sie reden
und wir reden eigentlich schon darüber
hakan das irgendwie mit uns sind wir da
mit drin dritter weltkrieg ja versteht
man ja jeder deutsche macht sich darüber
sorgen und natürlich ist dass die
haustür das wichtigste was vor der
haustür passiert aber momentan ist es
doch so dass wir die ukraine immer noch
völlig im stich lassen wir haben hier
zwar ein bisschen waffen her geliefert
aber die meisten waffen waren schrott
oder sind zu spät gekommen oder sind
nicht genug das sollten wir uns nicht
ernsthaft mal gedanken darüber machen ob
da momentan wirklich schnell genug alles
gemacht wird zum einen um waffen zu
liefern so viele wir haben so viele wir
haben um diese schreckens raketen
abzuschießen die putin jedem moment wo
ich gerade sitze hier auf diesen ort
schießen kann tun wir das erste und das
zweite ist tun denn ganz kurz das war
nicht an sie gerichtet es mir geht es
eher um die allgemeine debatte die wir
auch hier insgesamt in deutschland und
in europa führen und das zweite ist ich
glaube wir haben bei den sanktionen noch
längst nicht alles gemacht mir fehlt da
vor allem die persönliche komponente was
ist denn eigentlich mit putins geheimen
töchtern was ist denn mit putins
immobilien was ist denn mit den
angehörigen auch schulen universitäten
überall da habe ich noch nicht genügend
gehört darüber dass künftig alles was
westlich ist für leute die den kreml
direkt unterstützen nicht mehr
zugänglich sein muss wir brauchen auch
viel härtere sanktionen
als sie merkt wollen sie nach was
entgegnen sonst würde ich jetzt zu herrn
strunz weitergeben
willing klar widersprechen niemand hat
weil ich kann das für die union sagen
die ukraine auf geben ganz im gegenteil
ist das im januar noch in einer zdf
talkshow mit einem politiker der fdp da
wurde das argument vorgetragen na ja wir
sollten gar keine waffen liefern weil es
bisher gar nicht möglich überhaupt die
ukraine zu verteidigen immer habe ich
vehement widersprochen und genau das
gefordert was sie gerade gesagt haben
zusammen zwei dinge unterscheiden
hochkomplexe waffensysteme jetzt in die
ukraine zu liefern macht wenig sinn wenn
man daran lange menschen ausbilden muss
aber die alle waffen jetzt sofort
eingesetzt werden können die sinn machen
ich bin dafür dass wir diese liefern
herzlichen dank noch für die antwort und
dann kommen wir damit weiter zu der
these von claus strunz heute abend gut
ist setzt er dass die diskussion nahtlos
fort ich glaube jeder ob am stammtisch
oder in
politischen kreisen ob in der familie
mit den kindern oder
eben unter freunden diskutiert glaube
ich jeder jetzt wo führt das hin also
wie geht das aus wo führt das hin und
gibt es eigentlich noch einen plausiblen
ausweg aus der
dauerhaften krisen um nicht zu sagen
kriegssituation und wenn man es dreht
und wendet glaube ich dass ein punkt
sein kann der bisher ab und zu mal
genannt wird ich glaube nur die
neutralität der ukraine liefert
überhaupt noch eine möglichkeit für
frieden und es ist eine ziemlich brutale
sache weil die ukraine natürlich zu
recht sagt wir wollen ins westliche
bündnis wir wollen in die nato wir
wollen in die eu das alles von all
diesen wünschen und forderungen und
vorstellungen müsste die ukraine
zurücktreten warum weil dann auf der
anderen seite wladimir putin der als
einen seiner kriegsgründe die
neutralität der ukraine und die
demilitarisierung entmilitarisierung der
ukraine genannt hat sozusagen zustimmen
kann und schon wenn man das sagt uns mw
müssen wir jetzt dinge in betracht
ziehen denen wladimir putin der
kriegstreiber der touran der despot der
kriegsverbrecher zustimmen kann ich
fürchte am ende ist dass die bedingung
um in eine friedliche zukunft gehen zu
können das modell dafür ist das modell
österreich österreich hat 1955 sich zu
einer neutralität bekannt also wäre es
nicht ein weg in die zukunft die ukraine
mit dem modell österreich und der
neutralität in kontakt zu bringen ein
weg in die zukunft der uns allen dann
die möglichkeit gebe das als ich sage
jetzt bewusst nicht kriegsziel sondern
als einigungs ziel anzustreben
ja also als österreicher
alle bauchkrämpfe zusammen wenn ich das
höre dass die ukraine nach
österreichischem vorbild überlebens soll
das problem ist das wird sie nicht
dazu muss man auch sagen das modell
neutralität lag schon am tisch also wir
haben ja als dem militär aufmarsch zu
diesem krieg stattfand mehrere monate
gehabt wo verschiedene kanzler
präsidenten versucht haben zu vermitteln
versucht haben zu verhandeln wo sie alle
selber auch viele punkte auf den tisch
gebracht hat die putin von einem krieg
hätte abbringen können hätte er den
krieg nicht gewollt und nur diesen krieg
gewollt um die ukraine zu unterwerfen
einer davon war die frage ob man auf den
nato-beitritt verzichten würde das
problem ist russland gibt sich zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt mit der so einer
neutralität nicht
zufrieden es will eine entwaffnete
neutralität eben eine österreichische
weil österreich militärisch während des
ganzen kalten krieges schwach war es
wird sogar über die österreichische
neutralität hinausgehen in österreich
fallen in seiner anfangszeit
amerikanische militär unterstützung
hörte wir hatten sehr viel vor im
militär eade wir hatten unsere ganzen
offiziere der ersten generation in den
usa ausgebildet und wir hatten sehr
intensive kontakte vor allen dingen mit
der nato in italien also österreich
hätte zum kriegsschauplatz süd gehört im
fall eines eines totalen krieges
zwischen der nato und dem warschauer
pakt und wir hatten sehr viele starke
verbindungen in unseren italienischen
kollegen weil wir sozusagen dann im
kriegsfall denen unterstanden wehren
dass auch das lehnt putin ab er will
eine verteidigungs lose ukraine eine
wurde diesen krieg zu jeder sekunde und
für jedes interesse dass ihm gerade
durch den kopf geht sofort unter
besseren bedingungen wieder fortsetzen
kann als er ihn jetzt führt und das ist
das problem
oder das ist der grund warum die ukraine
das zu recht abgelehnt wenn die ukraine
aus diesem krieg hervor geht und wie sie
aus diesem ukraine aus diesem krieg
hervorgeht es gibt zwei bedingungen
erstens siehst souverän die regierung
der präsident wird vom ukrainischen volk
bestimmt und von niemand anderem und das
zweite ist wehrhaft in welcher form auch
immer aber das wäre ja das werden ja
zwei bedingungen die mit auf den tisch
müssen jetzt sagen sie zur echten putin
wird sich damit nicht zufrieden geben
mit dem argument allerdings kann man
praktisch gar nichts anbieten mit dem
argument bleibt er die situation der
ukraine ich formuliere ist jetzt mal aus
der position des freundes der ukraine
bleibt sie
auch eine art drohung an den westen
nämlich entweder ihr seid schuld daran
dass wir untergehen oder wir ziehen euch
in eine nicht mehr kalkulierbare
eskalation das ist ja im grunde dass das
ist ja die ansage von selensky mehr oder
weniger auf deutsch übersetzt und ich
finde dass dieser weg wehrhaft und
selbstbestimmt also selbstbewusst
zwischen den blöcken das finde ich ein
modell das sich noch nicht aufgeben
würde
vielleicht denkt wladimir putin im
angesicht der kriegshandlungen auch noch
mal neu auf was anderes kann man ja gar
nicht setzen weil sonst kann man sich
ihm gleich ergeben hätte sie mehr ist es
ein modell was man denken könnte was
claus strunz ihr krebs gezählt
die zeit ist vorbei und dieses diese
idee von claus strunz hat einen fehler
sie unterstellt es gibt zwei aggressive
teile zwei parteien die sich
gegenüberstehen beide aggressiv sind und
beide sich überfallen wollen das ist
nicht richtig es gibt einen aggressiven
start unter der führung von putin nicht
das russische volk aber die russische
regierung die ihren einfluss durch
expansion durch aggression geld machen
will und es gibt einen selbst
verteidigungsbündnis das heißt nadel er
hat es ist doch absurd herrscht uns dass
die nato oder der eu dass staaten aus
diesem verbund russland anhalten wollen
dass lettland estland das baltikum polen
russland überfallen oder die ukraine
nach moskau marschiert das ist absurd er
hat auch keine angst vor einer
militärischen bedrohung sondern er hat
einst vom verlust seiner wirkungsmacht
in dieser region dass er eben nicht
militärisch handeln kann und ich will es
ihnen noch an einem anderen also in
allen an einem anderen beispiel sagen
wir glauben daran dass staaten selbst
bestimmt sind das regierung frei gewählt
werden müssen und wenn ein staat sich
entscheidet sich diesem oder jenem
bündnis anzuschließen dann haben dass
die anderen staaten zu respektieren und
das polen beispielsweise in
selbstbestimmung sich der eu der nato
anschließt ist das gute recht des
polnischen volkes übrigens wäre ist auch
das gute recht wieder aus eu nato
auszutreten in diesem falle würde ja
wenn man putins argumentation folgt
hätte die nato hätte die bundesrepublik
eine recht in polen ein zu streiten weil
man sagen würde polen gehört nicht mehr
zum es hat gute beziehung zu russland
wir fühlen uns bedroht das geht nicht
was gerade passiert ist die neutralität
eines staates die immer 1 gehabt haben
von russland überfallen zu werden von
moskau beeinflusst zu werden und das mit
putin nicht deswegen ist der
reingegangen und das kann die
wertegemeinschaft der sie angehört nicht
akzeptieren ok ich kann ihre
argumentation folgen ich finde sie in
weiten teilen überzeugend aber was folgt
aus ihr außer die totale unterwerfung
unter putin wir reden nur über die
ukraine wir reden nicht über er betritt
nato gebiet dann haben wir ja klare
verhältnisse wir reden über die zukunft
der ukraine der menschen dort die jetzt
millionenfach aus dem land fliehen
müssen was ist unser angebot was ist
unser jetzt sag ich's doch was ist unser
kriegsziel einigungs ziel als westen als
deutschland was legen die auf den tisch
ich sage die neutralität wäre ein
erstrebenswertes ziel die hürden sind
mir klar sie sagen die zeit ist drüber
weg gegangen aber welche zeit ist dann
jetzt angebracht geben wir die frage
doch mal zu paul in kiew paul du hast
doch bestimmt los zu antworten
ja klaus dürfte tatsächlich die größte
frage und das größte problem auf ich
will vielleicht mal aus ukrainischer
perspektive sagen warum ist so schwierig
ist für die ukraine überhaupt in
irgendeine verhandlung zu gehen oder
irgendetwas zu unterschreiben wenn das
denn aus putin sich möglich wäre 1994
wurde der ukraine eine
sicherheitsgarantie gegeben und zwar
schon russland und dem westen im
gegenzug hat die ukraine die atomwaffen
abgegeben das vergessen immer viele
ursprünglich war die ukraine genauso wie
russland eine atommacht die wurden 1994
abgegeben weil man gesagt hat wir werden
euch niemals angreifen
wir sehen diese garantie hat zu nichts
geführt das heißt all das was jetzt
kommt wenn man sagen würde okay es ist
eine dermaßen eine militärische
übermacht auf russischer seite wir sind
bereit hier neutralität zu geben wobei
das
innenpolitisch ein riesiges problem wäre
weil viele viele menschen das nicht
wollen aber nehmen wir an man würde das
machen wie kann man denn putin vertrauen
das er sagt okay ich gehe da nicht rein
ich mach das nicht wer wir so lieben
denn vertrauen das er in einem halben
jahr das nicht tut oder am nächsten ja
dass das ist das große problem dass
große den er macht aber ich gebe klaus
recht was ist dann die lösung ich muss
sagen ich habe keine antwort darauf ob
diese und ich finde ich war deshalb auch
weil die ganz kurzen letzter satz weil
wladimir putin ja sagt die ukraine gibt
es gar nicht das ist alles russland also
ich ja das ist das dilemma gar keine
frage aber ich frage mich auch wenn die
menschen in der ukraine sagen wir wollen
diese neutralität nicht sondern wir
wollen dass der westen uns hilft laden
sie auch eine große moralische
verantwortung auf ihren schultern denn
das bedeutet wenn wir sterben sollen
solltet ihr im westen auch sterben denn
ihr sollt dann in diese kriegerische
handlung eintreten diese forderung liegt
er auf dem tisch lasst uns nicht allein
ihr müsst uns helfen ihr müsst luft die
die den luftraum sperren das bedeutet
ein eingriff der nach internationalen
gesetzmäßigkeiten gedeutet werden kann
als sozusagen die nächste
eskalationsstufe und auf die wartet
wladimir putin uhr also glaube ich dass
man den gedanken der neutralität zu
schmerzhaft er sein mag und die klinke
ist natürlich kann man einem mann
vertrauen der ein gerade überfallen hat
der gerade die brüder die schwestern die
kinder die eltern
töten lässt kann man dem vertrauen die
antwort liegt auf der hand nein aber was
bleibt sonst und das hat mich zu dem
gedanken gebracht von allen optionen
dritter weltkrieg durch
eskalation ukraine geht unter unter
russischer herrschaft irgendwelche neuen
grenzen werden gemacht und putin hat
gewonnen gefällt mir irgendwie die idee
wenn man das so sagen darf dass ich den
realität noch mal einen einen weg bahnt
der gedanke der neutralität noch am
allerbesten aus unserer sicht
wenn du aber dann möchte ich eine
jährigen frage
aber nicht nur die carina ich würde
bezweifeln ich würde bezweifeln dass
selbst wladimir putin das akzeptieren
würde wie soll er denn sagen in er hat
in seinen reden in seiner letzten
ansprache ganz klar gesagt die ukraine
gehört zu russland das bedeutet ja er
will sie sich einverleiben und sie soll
in dem sinne kein staat bleiben dann
würde da bleibt mir putin auch die
neutralität nicht reichen klaus
also wenn man nicht daran kleve letzter
gedanke wenn man nicht daran glaubt dass
man wladimir putin etwas hinlegen kann
was ihnen vielleicht interessieren
könnte diplomatisch als politischen
erfolg ich komme ja immer von diesem
furchtbaren gedanken dass er sein
gesicht wahren können muss nach der
auseinandersetzung
es interessiert mich eigentlich gar
nicht ob ein mörder und kriegsverbrecher
sein gesicht wahren kann aber es scheint
mir der einzige ausweg zu sein dann
müssen alle die sagen neutralität ist
keine option doch was anderes auf
tischen und sagen dann lasst es uns so
versuchen und das habe ich noch nicht
erkannt ich würde mich auch ich sage es
jetzt flapsig schock verlieben wenn ein
anderes modell das mir so plausibel
erschienen wie die neutralität die
schwierig genug ist
den krieg erst einmal verlieren oder
zumindest so großen schaden nehmen dass
er sich mit dem über mit der realität
überhaupt ab findet dass er einen ausweg
braucht denn zurzeit geht ja nur auf die
maximalforderungen auf eine totale
entwaffnung der ukraine und das kann
kann nicht das ziel sein und dann ist es
auch so hell die ukraine braucht die
ukraine kann nicht auf treu und glauben
spielen die ukraine braucht eine
wehrhafte situation in der sie sich
verteidigen kann ob sie sich durch
allianz mit anderen verteidigen kann
oder ob sie genauso wie das im fall
jugoslawiens nach 1948 war wie das im
fall österreich nach 1955 war wobei
österreich hat zu einem guten teil
versammelt und das später nochmal teuer
gekommen als eine andere geschichte die
in österreich interessiert oder ob das
etwa schweden war im kalten krieg oder
die schweiz aus einer selbst
verteidigungsfähigkeit und bei vielen
neutralen staaten die vorher
angesprochen habe eine unterstützte
selbst verteidigungsfähigkeit die usa
haben 1956 als die russischen panzer
durch budapester wollten sofort eine
garantie ausgesprochen dass jede
verletzung österreichs unmittelbare
militärische konsequenzen durch die usa
hervorrufen sie haben nuklear
bewaffneten flugzeuge nach mitteleuropa
verschickt die service haben das sofort
verstanden das hat niemand für die
ukraine gemacht und wenn man es wenn
sich der westen dann auch nicht bewusst
ist was es bedeutet einem bündnis freien
hoch verwundbaren staat hier zu haben
dann können wir alle papierform in der
neutralität über den buckel schmeißen
und weil potente das papier nicht
interessiert den interessiert knacken
meine panzer das oder nicht wir bleiben
beim thema putin und kommen noch zu
einem thema was mir heute abend sehr
wichtig ist uns war dass putin nicht
russland ist die wut über putins
angriffskrieg ist groß in deutschland
merkt auch hier in der runde doch sie
verwandelt sich fälschlicherweise auch
in zorn auf unbeteiligte nachbarn mit
studenten und russische restaurants als
er jeder mit russischem hintergrund
putin fan das darf nicht sein also mich
besonders schockiert eine mail über die
zuerst die zeit berichtete die
direktorin der universitätsklinik
münchen schrieb zitat aufgrund der
schweren völkerrechtsverletzungen durch
den offenbar geistig gestört autokraten
putin bis hierhin stimmen noch zu jetzt
nicht mehr lehnen wir ab sofort
grundsätzlich die behandlung russischer
patienten ab ukrainische patient sind
natürlich herzlich willkommen sie hatte
diese mail an eine beraterin verschickt
über umwege landete diese dann auf
facebook auf anfrage von zeit online
teil des kakaos dann mit dass es sich
keineswegs um ein offizielles statement
der klinik handel die absenderin hat in
einer sehr emotionalen situation ihre
persönliche meinung mitgeteilt dies aber
inzwischen bereits bedauert ich sage es
nicht gern und ich sage das nicht oft
aber es sind schon menschen für weniger
zurückgetreten als für sowas und es ist
nur ein symbol für das was in
deutschland los auch wenn ich finde nach
acht redaktion haben sich den letzten
tagen großen gewarnt die in deutschland
leben und gebeten dass wir uns hier in
der runde für sie einsetzen das möchte
ich hiermit gerne tun putin ist nicht
russland hass auf alles was russisch ist
darf nicht die antwort auf putins krieg
seien ich bin nicht die einzige es heute
anspricht herz im jahr zu haben heute
auch in der union mario czaja der
amtierende generalsekretär hat sollte
auch ein statement abgegeben deswegen
würde ich direkt zu ihm übergeben mit
der these ja ich teile das auch ganz
ausdrücklich mario czaja das gemacht
heute in dem statement wie fand richtig
und klar und deutlich so sich mehrzad
einen offenen brief geschrieben auch an
den unter russlanddeutschen
das ist er wir dürfen diesen politischen
konflikt diesen krieg von putin nicht zu
einem teil unserer gesellschaft werden
lassen wo menschen ausgegrenzt werden
weil sie eine herkunft haben wie zb die
russische und ehrlicher weise können wir
darauf stolz sein was wir in deutschland
haben wissen sie in dem hochhaus in dem
ich groß geworden bin da gab es im
prinzip drei gruppen das waren russen
und quali nah und polen im laufe der
jahre wir haben zusammen als kinder
gespielt später als wir etwas älter
waren haben wir zusammen auch was
gegessen und
heimat kurz weil er mit dem essen das
hätten sie mir nicht abgekauft und so
haben wir denn wir sind in einem langen
wir kennen uns bis heute und deswegen
sage ich teile das ganz ausdrücklich das
ist putins krieg und dass die
russlanddeutschen kalina die von dort
gekommen sind das sind deutsche
staatsangehörige häufig und insofern
sage ich wir sind eine gesellschaft und
deswegen keine diskriminierung
paris die lage in kiew wenn du dort mit
den menschen spricht natürlich auch über
russland ist es dort auch dass man auch
feststellt was in der situation ehrlich
so anders als in deutschland ein
stückweit verständlicher ist dass der
hass auf alles russische groß ist oder
es anders als hier in deutschland
nein es ist natürlich sehr viel
intensiver als in deutschland aber man
muss sich das mal vorstellen ich meine
ist es ja nicht so dass nur wladimir
putin hier in einem panzer steht und die
ukraine angreift sondern eben hundert
tausende russische soldaten
ich stimme dem zu was er gesagt hat
natürlich gerade darf es nicht zu diesen
vorfällen kommen ist für mich eine
selbstverständlichkeit
dass das nicht passieren darf und
dagegen müssen uns alle wehren und
dennoch muss ich sagen es ist eben nicht
nur putins krieg denn es gibt sehr viele
menschen die dafür gesorgt haben dass
wladimir putin präsident wurde er war ja
auch mal ein anderer präsident das
stimmt zwar er war beliebt und ist
beliebt es gibt viele menschen peter
tiede macht das immer wieder sehr
eindrucksvoll unser reporter in russland
wenn er dort mit den menschen spricht
die kaufen ihm das alles ab dann kann
man sagen okay die sind jetzt vielleicht
alle brainwash durch diese massen
propaganda die es dort gibt wir haben
gerade gehört dass facebook jetzt auch
offiziell blockiert ist also russland
entwickelt sich momentan richtung
nordkorea aber dennoch hat natürlich die
russische gesellschaft eine
verantwortung dafür wer präsident
geworden ist und die russische
gesellschaft hat genauso eine
verantwortung dafür dass sie in diesem
moment als dieser krieg ausgebrochen ist
mit einer viel größeren anzahl von
menschen hätte demonstrieren müssen ich
weiß das ist alles leicht gesagt auch
aus der ukraine leicht gesagt als
reporter leicht gesagt der sich nicht
hiergegen die polizei stellen muss aber
ich würde mir wünschen und ich hätte
auch erwartet dass die zahl der
demonstranten gegen putin wesentlich
höher ist und wenn es einer sagen kann
paul bist du der sich jeden tag mit mut
in der ukraine in kiew auf welt also ich
finde es einer sagen darf dass du der du
darfst das verlangen an meinen augen
klasse sich diese breite ich würde
diesen von paul fast ein bisschen
zaghaft ausgesprochen gedanken noch
verstärken wollen jeder der putin
gewählt hat hat anteil an diesem krieg
mitschuld an diesem krieg den putin hat
sich ja quasi nicht irgendwie besonders
verwandelt also er hat sein äußeres
ziemlich verändert wenn man das so sagen
darf
ob freiwillig oder aus krankheitsgründen
wird der heftig diskutiert aber es war
ja völlig klar dass es sich nicht um
einen lupenreinen demokraten handelt den
mann der welt als es daher eine in
deutschland jedem klar
einer der unterirdischen setzte der
wahrscheinlich niemals gesagt wurde
gerhard schröder über wladimir putin und
da ist es ja auch immer schon so
eingeordnet worden und deswegen kann man
jetzt nicht per blanco scheint die
gesamte russische bevölkerung und
wählerschaft freisprechen ist nur diese
eine verrückte mann und seine seine
oligarchen clique unten war general ist
sondern das ist schon
der führt da schon aus was viele russen
für richtig halten das muss man sich
schon klar machen aber jetzt umgekehrt
darf daraus auch nicht der schluss
gezogen werden alle müssen wollen die
wollen kiew platt machen im gegenteil da
da da da tickt in mir auch so was was
für mich das ganze noch unvorstellbarer
macht also es gibt ganz viele
persönliche beziehungen in russischen
familien zur ukrainischen familien und
wahrscheinlich würde man bei den 150.000
soldaten ganz viele kennen die wenn sie
auf kiew schießen auf ihren cousinen
schießen oder auch in entfernteren
verwandten oder nahen verwandten also
das ist ja das ist ja quasi aus
deutscher sicht fast nur zu begreifen
wenn man sich vorstellt dass ich in der
bundeswehr ausgebildet worden bin um auf
die nva zu schießen ja also deutsch für
sie schießen auf deutsche das ist dann
noch die verrücktere steigerung von
allem hier allerdings um die freiheit zu
verteidigen
und nicht sie abzuschaffen so und das
finde ich ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger
punkt bei der beurteilt der russen die
gibt es halt nicht jetzt muss ich quasi
einen satz noch dazu sagen auch nicht
alle ukraine sind lupenreine demokraten
ja also auch da gilt es natürlich zu
unterscheiden nicht aber in dieser
stunde denn in dieser stunde kämpfen die
einen für die freiheit und die anderen
gegen die freiheit und dann hat man sich
als freiheitsliebender mensch nicht mehr
groß feind zu isolieren sondern dann
steht man auf der einen seite und gegen
die anderes hat ich will noch einen ganz
kurze frage an der zehn jahre stellen
ich brauche nur eine ganz kurze antwort
war leider was man kurz unterbrechen
jetzt sie merkt fanden sie heute die
sanktion gegen die opernsängerin
netrebko richtig von den opernhäusern
weltweit
das ist also in einer kurzen antwort
schwierig zu sagen ich finde dass sind
diejenigen also ich würde mir mehr
sanktionen wünschen übrigens gegen
diejenigen die das geld hier auch in
europa haben diejenigen die den
westlichen luxus den lebensstil gerne
pflegen in demokratien sie sicher fühlen
aber krieg mit ihrem geld finanzieren
ich habe darauf gehofft auf diese
antwort weil man nämlich an der antwort
gesehen hat so kurz und einfach ist es
gar nicht bei jeder persönlichkeit zu
erklären ob sie es russisches oder nicht
wir sind nach einer ganz kurzen
unterbrechung wieder zurück
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und wir wollen direkt zu
dem thema beziehungsweise eigentlich der
sache kommen warum ich heute unbedingt
herzberg in die verwendung haben wollte
und ich bin so froh dass er sich dazu
auch heute dann kurzfristig hat auch
überzeugen lassen nicht von mir sondern
von potsdam aus kaarst aber was ich dazu
nicht sagen wir sie haben gestern waren
sie an der polnisch ukrainischen grenze
und haben flüchtlinge besucht und ihn
auch geholfen und wir würden uns sehr
freuen wenn sie uns die eindrücke
schildern die sie dort gestern erlebt
haben hat sie mir
ja ich war nimmt grenzübergang
media profile eben einer der größten
trends übergangs profile an dem
automaten man bis zu 72 stunden zu fuß
gibt es stelle aber trotzdem viele
frauen dort die 24 stunden gewartet hat
kann man diesen super gau papiers
organisation vor ort so kamele
infrastruktur geschaffen haben auch in
einem polnischen grenzpolizei alles
zeigen das bringt diese drei
zugangspunkt haben dann platzt eine
familie zwar eine mutter mit drei
kindern hamburg musste sich angehörige
hatte und wusste nicht wie sie dorthin
kommen soll die grenzpolizisten zweite
mich ob ich helfen könnte ich habe dann
gesagt dann nehme ich sie mit yoga wir
nehmen sie mit ich war mit einem freund
zusammen da und dann kam noch eine
andere familie
ein rentnerpaar mit enkelin und dann
haben wir die gleich mit eingepackt und
sind mit unserer politik dann
freundlicher kritischen grenze bis nach
hamburg
und sie sind ja auch in einem durch
gefahren die ich im instagram post
gelesen habe was haben die menschen in
den vorort gesagt was wird dort jetzt
wirklich am meisten benötigt was ich
auch ganz ganz viele bürger in
deutschland fragen wie kann man helfen
ich würde sagen die hilfsbereitschaft
war selten so groß wie gerade in diesem
land ja absolut die hilfsbereitschaft
ist gigantisch nicht nur bei uns in
deutschland habe das heutige polen so in
der form auch noch nie erlebt man sieht
in warschau keine kein bus keine u-bahn
der nicht eine ukrainische flagge hat
auf den straßenschildern auf den
digitalen anzeigen in warschau auch auf
den polnischen autobahn wechseln die
verkehrshinweise dann mit hält ju ju
crane citizens auf englisch mit einer
helpline die dann eingeblendet wird also
eine unglaubliche solidarität überall
unserer englische flaggen und auch egal
ob regierung oder opposition ich werde
das hat putin geschafft in polen
regierung und opposition bei einer
richtigen politischen frage
zusammenzuführen und vielleicht selbst
sogar diejenige der richtig mal das
ukrainische volk noch einmal zusammen
gebracht hat aber zu der hilfe bitte das
würde ich sagen keine keine kleidung
schicken an die polnische grenze dort
kommt sehr sehr viel an aus polen auch
aus deutschland manchmal hat man den
eindruck da sagt wehmann was gutes tun
und wirft sachen mac die sowieso man gar
nicht mehr gebrauchen kann das kommt
dort an das ist nicht das was man
braucht auch bitte keine konserven in
deutschland kaufen und die dann mit
einem lkw nach polen bringen weil man
kann in polen sogar selbst im supermarkt
dinge einkaufen also man kann einfach
geldspende das hilft am ehesten wenn man
helfen will ich empfehle dazu entweder
ganz konkret initiativen vor ort auf der
polnischen seite
initiativen in der ukraine oder eben die
anerkannten hilfsorganisationen und zwar
von der aktion deutschland hilft jeder
der dort registrierten mit mathis
zertifiziert und dann lohnt sich an
gespendet klaus wir helfen ja auch bei
bild mit ein herz für kinder
für kinder doch eine groß angelegte
aktion gestartet kann man in all unseren
medien sehen das finde ich ganz ganz
fantastisch ich würde es ein bisschen an
einer stelle vielleicht anschaffen
wollen das was paul ziemlich arg über
die
altkleidersammlungen in
anführungszeichen sagt bewegt mich auch
also ich glaube dass die bilder über die
vielen menschen in not viele menschen in
deutschland extrem berühren und
gleichzeitig so eine art schlechtes
gewissen auslösen dass man nicht genau
weiß wie man helfen soll oder dass man
wüsste wie man helfen es soll aber es
ist so unbequem also hilft man lieber
nicht und dann schaut man mal im keller
ob man noch ein paar alte kleider die
man dann dahin schickt ich drücke es
einmalig wahrscheinlich der einzige der
das so sagt und da glaube ich müssen wir
noch zu uns finden also wenn eine
million menschen auf der flucht sind
oder vielleicht wie ich jetzt von der
uno gehört womöglich zehn millionen und
wir so nah dran sind dann ist es
natürlich mitten im alten winter pulli
nicht getan sondern dann ist die frage
haben wir gästezimmer haben wir super
wohnungen haben wir in villen platz für
menschen und ich finde dass es da
es gibt null zusammenhang und trotzdem
fühle ich den man kann schon sagen ein
russischer oligarch dem soll man sein
ganzes vermögen wegnehmen aber dann muss
man auch sagen wer jetzt hier in
deutschland ein großes vermögen hat den
immobilien der soll sie auch öffnen für
menschen in not und
ich habe ganz am anfang schon mal gesagt
dass ich angst habe vor den
lava bataillonen die dann beginnen
rumzulaufen die immer alles wissen wie
es gehen muss die immer alles
prophezeien und predigen dann muss man
auch selber dinge tun und das feld
unheimlich schwer ich habe diese
diskussion mit mir selber und meiner
familie auch gestern begonnen was was
tun wir denn und dann kommen da auch so
argumente naja aber dann wie ist es denn
dann sitzen alle beim frühstück zusammen
mit den fremden leuten und so das muss
man ja einmal auch analysieren weil wir
könnten natürlich noch viel mehr tun
anders gesagt wenn wir uns schon so
schwertun waffen zu schicken dann
sollten wir uns wenigstens um die
menschen kümmern die darunter leiden was
die waffen der anderen ihnen an tut und
dass das bewegt mich sehr und ich bin
weit davon entfernt zu sagen ihr müsst
ihr müsst ihr müsst ich sage nur dass es
auf euch wirken wenn ihr menschen seid
dann fällt euch sicher irgendwas gutes
ein was die abgabe des winter police und
der durch gelutscht schule schuhe
übersteigt ja dadurch vielleicht ein
punkt in verfügen mir geht es mehr als
ein punkt auch richtig wir erleben jetzt
eine unglaublich große welle an
hilfsbereitschaft aber
ich habe heute zum beispiel eine einem
einfachen besuch bürger helfen bürgern
bei mir in iserlohn die das übrigens
nicht nur jetzt tun sondern die ganze
zeit also über jahre hinweg menschen
helfen die auf der flucht sind und die
not sind und meine bitte ist an
diejenigen die heute helfen wollen aber
noch nicht wissen wie macht euch den
zettel liegt in den kalender für in
einem monat oder in zwei monaten drei
monaten wenn vielleicht man gar nicht
mehr so genau hinschauen wo es
vielleicht auch zu lasten wird weil es
wird auch mit herausforderung versehen
sein wenn so viele menschen nachholen
kommen nach deutschland kommen um dann
auch sagen jetzt sind wir dabei wenn
keine kamera man hinschaut der vielen
herzlichen dank für diesen aufruf der
sehr wichtig und ja auch ehrlich gesagt
im sinne von dieser talkshow 48 deswegen
noch mal vielen dank und sie bleiben uns
erzählen der runde erhalten wenn es
jetzt auch zur these geht die haben uns
ja auch eine mitgebracht und sagen
nämlich was die ukraine jetzt braucht
eigentlich ja die ukraine braucht es in
erster linie waffen werden wir von
spenden reden ich habe es natürlich
nicht da aber ich kann auf das
spendenkonto der ukrainischen
streitkräfte aus dem hut zaubern bzw aus
dem handy und sie brauchen natürlich
mehr als die spenden von mir denn die
ukraine steht mit dem rücken zur wand
das erklärte kriegsziel russland ist es
die ukraine auszuwischen das
unabhängiger staat als eigenständige
nation
das potenzial feministisch als
entnazifizierung beschreiben ist nichts
anderes ist ein ausradieren der
politischen kulturellen der
journalistischen eliten der
intellektuell
der westen hat allen grund
sogar aus einfach aus planken
eigeninteresse die ukraine hier
militärisch zu unterstützen
denn wenn die ukraine fällt wenn dort
wie in der dnl nr 1 besatzungs
verschieden dass sich dann mit nordkorea
darum buhlt den letzten platz in der
freedom house ranking zu erfüllen werden
sich dass die ukraine nicht gefallen
lassen sie werden widerstand leisten
dass für den partisanenkrieg geben was
bedeutet das wiederum russland wird
zehntausende
truppen der inneren sicherheit also
nationalgarde fsb entsenden um diesen
aufstand niederzuschlagen diese leute
kommen von rot nach russland zurück
behandeln die eigene position wie es in
der ukraine gelernt haben und ukraine
versteift und russland verstärkt sich
drauf wie das putin gestern schon
angeklungen hat dass der westen an allem
schuld ist das im grunde dass nur ein
produkt das hier ist und dass man das
altbewährte mittel militärische kraft
militärische einschüchterung dazu
gebrauchen wird um uns abzuschrecken und
ich sage das unter anführungszeichen
sich in die um nicht wieder
anführungszeichen inneren
angelegenheiten russlands einzumischen
das wird der putin-sprecher sein wir
werden keinen ruhigen kalten krieg haben
wir werden einen heißen kalten krieg
haben einen der äußerst instabil ist und
in einem in der die eskalation im grunde
jeden tag an der wand geschrieben ist in
dem sinne ist es unser ganz eigenes das
interesse jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass die
ukraine in diesem krieg zumindest
militärisch unentschieden aussteigt und
ihn auf jeden fall überlebt als ukraine
als souveräne ob gering
paul du hast es hoffentlich gehört ja
was gibt es darauf zu antworten wie
viele waffen braucht die ukraine
wie viele es schwer zu sagen aber
definitiv kann ich sagen vor der sendung
mit vitali klitschko gesprochen der
heute an verschiedenen stellen unterwegs
war auch in kirchen muss sich das so
vorstellen
umkirch warum wird längst sehr heftig
gekämpft
in den außenbezirken da sieht es ein
bisschen aus wie in teilen syriens
bereits so sehr schießt russland dort
mit raketen system rein es geht vor
allem darum dass man diese raketen
abwehren kann das ist kompliziert
zumindest teilweise und dennoch gibt es
dafür möglichkeiten und da sagt die
ukraine brauchen wir dringend viel viel
mehr woran es die ukraine nicht mangelt
und das hat putin überrascht ist die
moral der truppen die man dort auch
treffen kann die wirklich überall
unterwegs sind versuchen hier auch hier
wo ich bin diese stadt in irgendeiner
form sicher zu halten es ist trotzdem
wahnsinnig ein geister stimmung dort in
den straßen fährt eigentlich niemand
mehr es läuft auch niemand mehr so
wirklich über die straße aber was die
waffen angeht sagt man das geht zu
langsam die europäer brauchen zu lange
man orientiert sich momentan eigentlich
vor allem richtung usa und das ist finde
ich ein wenig traurig dass wir europäer
da im vergleich zu den usa
wieder bürokratischer langsamer und
nicht hands-on sind ich glaube wir
müssen alles alles alles tun um wirklich
hier europäisch zu liefern denn ich
erinnere mich wie 2014 dort von vielen
eu politikern europäischen flaggen
verteilt wurden am mai dann ich sag das
jetzt mal symbolisch sie standen
zumindest mit dabei und die ukraine die
jetzt die europäische die damals die
europäische flagge gehisst haben gewählt
haben auf dem majdan die stehen jetzt
auf dem schlachtfeld und drohen von
putin getötet zu werden
herzau dann die deutschen wirklich so
viel mehr als die amerikaner vor allem
mit blick auf die sanktionen muss ich
sagen also amerika zaudert gerade ja
auch ein bisschen mit blick auf den
energiepreis auf dem meer wird es dort
auch debattiert wie man das mit den
bürgern schafft sind wir gerade so viel
schlechter behandeln als
amerikaner haben auch mit einigen sachen
länger gebraucht zb der flugverbotszone
aber es war richtig es ist richtig was
sie sagen wir haben gezeigt wir haben
gezögert und als schon alle anderen
gesagt haben wir brauchen die aussetzung
von swift was deutschland wie am ende
noch die einzigen waren vorher noch mit
viktor orban die einzigen die dagegen
waren sind super hat schneller
entschieden als wir und insofern jahr
wir haben nicht schnell gehandelt bis
letzte woche sonntag als bundeskanzler
scholz einer regierungserklärung
abgegeben hat waren wir diejenigen die
gebäude ist haben und die nicht geholfen
haben dann gab es die wände und die war
richtig und das hat scholz das würde ich
auch als opposition sagen das war sie
angekündigt hat war richtig ich habe als
der vertreter der neutralität noch eine
frage wenn man den gedanken näher tritt
also waffen waffen waffen sie haben
einfacher gedanke insofern leicht
verständlich was wäre dann ihr szenario
wie das weitergeht glauben sie dass man
in der jetzigen situation die er schon
weit fortgeschritten ist
der armee putins noch wirklich
widerstand leisten kann so dass das
passiert achtung meine these ist immer
noch im raum dass putin so viel schaden
nimmt und so viel gegendruck spürt dass
man überhaupt am verhandlungstisch mit
das eigene mann kommen kann ja also ich
würde hier die parallelen zu 19 39
finnland ziehen stalin war ja auch jetzt
nicht zimperlich und war jetzt auch
nicht der beste menschenfreund und hat
sich auch nicht um die menschenrechte
geschert aber irgendwann war es einfach
für die sowjetunion damals zu
schwierig oder zu zum problematisch dass
man hier in finnland vorgeführt wird
finden an stand natürlich auch vor der
totalen erschöpfung finnland hat aber
auch zumindest von schweden zum teil von
frankreich und großbritannien waffen
bekommen
um sich zu verteidigen
und es hat dann nach 40 tagen wir sind
das am tag 9 der kriege finnland hat
nach 40 tagen einen
natürlich schlechten aber einen
souveränen frieden und einem bewaffneten
frieden erreicht und wir sind zurzeit
wenn man sich die letzten
verhandlungsrunden zwischen der ukraine
und russland anschaut leider noch weit
davon entfernt dass putin einem
souveränen und einem bewaffneten einen
wehrhaften frieden für die ukraine
zustimmt wie immer daran ausschaut
ukraine die ukraine dann ein sehr
lebhaftes parlament das müsste alm
zustimmen wasilewski aushandelt das
vergessen hier bei uns auch die leute
der der ist nicht gut in der iss sein
wort ist nicht ein macht aber wenn er
einen kompromiss aus handelt dem denen
die rhader zustimmt dann dann gilt der
was dann genau drin ist dem möchte ich
nicht vorgreifen bis dahin kommt ist
noch viel militärische widerstand zu
leisten und wir haben natürlich die
logistischen probleme der russischen
armee die condor ist die die vier
kolonnen das ging bei uns alles durch
die durch die medien aber das gilt ja
für die ukrainische seite genauso die
russischen panzer die hier alle
abgeschlossen sind die haben sich nicht
hin selbst in flammen aufgelöst die
wurden abgeschossen und da wo die
munition verbraucht und der munition
verbrauch war enorm auch zur
raketenabwehr die die ukraine hat es
geschafft sogar russische ballistische
raketen abzuschießen mit alten
sowjetischen flugabwehrraketen aber auch
die werden knapp und
desto länger sie das kann desto länger
seine luftwaffe noch betreiben kann
desto länger sie den luftraum zumindest
temporär freihalten kann solange sie
noch drohnen operieren kann die gegen
diese konvois gehen die auch artillerie
in der tiefe angreifen solange sie noch
eine funktionierende panzer abwehr hat
die die verhindert dass die stadtzentren
möglich eingenommen wird so lange hat
die ukraine eine chance einen frieden
auszuhandeln der kein friedhof frieden
ist und er nicht auf potenziell passiert
kein friedhofs frieden haben gestern mit
einer kleinen tradition begonnen die
holzer tradition mit paul kannst du noch
mal in 40 sekunden die letzten 40
sekunden der sendung ich hab sogar 45
noch einmal deinen kriegstag heute noch
einmal schildern für die die später als
zugeschaut haben
noch einmal zu schildern ist schwierig
weil sich jede minute was neues gerade
eben hinter uns hat man schüsse gehört
im stadtzentrum das nicht das erste mal
aber immer wieder ganz kurz davor immer
wieder explosionen sirenen also und das
gefühl in dieser stadt und das ist das
was die leute fertig macht was für einen
terror sorgt immer das gefühl zu haben
du bist jetzt ins bett aber du warst
morgen auch und der große putin angriff
hat begonnen
und die großen raketensysteme werden
eingesetzt und du schaust wehrlos zu wie
deine stadt zerbombt wird wie einst
aleppo in syrien
lassen wir es so enden mit deinen worten
herzlichen dank an meine gäste und wir
sehen uns montagabend wieder um 20 15
[Musik]